so I want to talk about this incredible
vitamin k2 okay I have other videos on
this but this is some additional data
now vitamin k1 has everything to do with
coagulating proteins is basically
binding proteins and helping forming
clots okay
stopping bleeding it's very very
important it's also involved in bone
information and it's recycled okay so
your body usually is not very deficient
in vitamin k1 it's in leafy greens k2 on
the other hand is very different a lot
of people are deficient in it it's not
recycled very readily and it basically
binds calcium in the bone and it also
helps transport calcium out of the soft
tissues so it takes calcium from the
places that shouldn't be and it puts it
into place that it should be but it's
also involved in your metabolism as far
as the mitochondria in turning that food
into energy so let's say for example you
exercise and you last a certain time
period you kind of like run at a gas or
you don't have the endurance k2 can help
you go longer it can increase your
cardiac output I've noticed this when I
I had this huge hill at my house it's
gigantic right and for quite a long time
I could only make it halfway out start
taking k2 and I've also taken other
things like b1 from some other
supplements I have but vitamin k2 is
just dramatic it just allows me to come
right up without any stops it just gives
me more endurance and more a sustained
strength so it's quite remarkable it's
but it all has to do with what's
happening at the cellular level inside
the mitochondria there's several
different types of vitamin k2 Mk
versions you have MK 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 so you have a lot of
different versions of k2 but the ones
you can get in supplement form are MK 4
and MK 7 the one that I recommend is MK
7 because it's natural it's not
synthetic
but vitamin k2 originates from bacteria
okay in animals and humans we could
actually make a little bit of it but in
grass-fed animal products and liver egg
yolks meats cheese certain cheese's
I said liver already and also fermented
foods there's a product called Nadeau
which is a fermented soybean I think
they use it in Japan that has vitamin k2
now who would benefit from vitamin k2
those people who have a history of
taking anti acids usually always
deficient in k2 if you had a history of
taking a lot of antibiotics you're gonna
have a deficiency in k2 as well or
you're on statins or you have gi
problems any type of diverticulitis or
earlobe bowel syndrome or IBS or Crohn's
any type of scar tissue
this is the fat soluble vitamin so we
need a good digestive system to absorb
it if you're taking vitamin d3 you need
to be taking k2 because they both work
together if you take just vitamin d3
without k2 potentially you could
increase your calcium too high in the
tissues because we want the k2 to pull
out that calcium excess if you're taking
calcium you need to take k2 because k2
tells the calcium where to go if you're
menopausal okay you need k2y to actually
prevent bone loss okay heart problems
cardiovascular weaknesses the main thing
about Kate - is it actually prevents
calcification through the arteries the
blood vessels the soft tissue so it can
work to help keep the arteries free of
calcium deposits and also if you're
pregnant you need k2
very very important also if you have
arthritis k2 can help you or
inflammation it can help you alright
thanks for watching
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg comm it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out